bom dia quinze de janeiro de 2009 o
comandante sully decola do aeroporto de
laguardia em nova york e ainda
terminando os protocolos de decolagem
ele se encontra com uma revoada de
gansos gansos enormes que estavam
migrando esses garotos entraram em
colisão com os motores com as turbinas e
apagaram as duas turbinas de repente ele
tava
e sem motor play nando com 155 pessoas
mas seis tripulantes em cima de uma das
maiores cidades da terra
a e agora ele teve 35 segundos
a pensar ir paro e pensou
o 208 segundos depois ele pousou no rio
no meio de nova york e esse dia ficou
conhecido como
é o milagre do rio hudson depois de uma
investigação super criteriosa onde ele
quase saiu é culpado como irresponsável
já que tinham dois aeroportos a 11 km de
distância mas ele jogou que a razão de
descida do espiral não era suficiente
ele decidiu fazer isso ele parou em sono
olá meu nome é menor e o rafael eu sou o
fundador de uma homeschool
carinhosamente batizada pelos alunos de
minorulandia
e e eu estou usando 208 segundos
e para sugerir para você calma e para
que eu não tô negando o caos eu não tô
negando a pandemia eu não tô negando o
causa econômico não tô negando o caos
político não mas mas espera você precisa
pensar calma às pessoas que não estão
morrendo pela doença tomar tando pela
política as pessoas que não estão
entubados para poder respirar então
esganando
é porque por motivos partidários tão
calma eu não vivo num mundo cor de rosa
só tô falando que você precisa ainda que
seja 35 segundos
e naqueles 35 segundos no meio do caos o
cara parou e pensou e ele fez um milagre
da vida dele e de 155 pessoas
e talvez seja hora agora de você também
parar e pensar no que que você vai fazer
a calma calma como os médicos fazerem
que eles precisam fazer calma calma para
os empreendedores acharem saídas e calma
para quem perdeu o pessoas
a
e se levantar de novo calma
e isso não é não é uma uma atitude de
alienação é uma atitude de sabedoria
a calma
e aí
e quando tudo pede um pouco mais de
calma até quando o corpo pede um pouco
mais de alma a vida é tão rara
g1
e em quanto tempo acelera e pede pressa
eu me recuso faço hora vou na valsa
[Música]
é a vida é tão rara enquanto todo mundo
espera a cura do mal e a loucura finge
que isso tudo é normal eu finjo ter
paciência o mundo vai girando cada vez
mais veloz a gente espera do mundo eo
mundo espera de nós
um pouco mais de paciência
[Música]
e aí